hey guys Pete here are you ready for
some more Game of Thrones season 8
filming news spoiler warning of course
as the video title says this does
include production spoilers and
speculation doesn't give any answers
away directly just gives us some stuff
to think about but if you're trying to
avoid those kinds of spoilers in the
first place then this video is not for
you so I made a video yesterday about
Jon Snow seen in costume on set in
Croatia this is something that had been
speculated on but we weren't sure that
it was gonna happen and we saw him in
his full-on Northern first it was
notable that he was not wearing long
claw and he was not wearing the
breastplate that we've seen him wear as
the king in the north
throughout season 7 but other than that
for all intents and purposes he seemed
to be in King's Landing as I was editing
that video more stuff came out in the
local press in Croatia showing Lena
Headey was in town and she was filming
just a couple nice shots of her through
a window in her new getup it's been
updated a little bit since last season
it's got a little bit more gold going on
a little more Lannister of a look to it
and what's interesting here again is Jon
Snow is involved and seems to be meeting
with Circe herself now I'd point out
that the mountain was in town so he's
there we see some of her Queen's Guard
there and there's another shot that
shows gold cloaks on the wall and it
seems like odd placement because they're
right in front of a window where people
are able to take pictures and before you
jump to the conclusion that they're
doing all this just to throw us off
because of what they said before I just
don't really think that's the case these
actors cost money getting this set and
everything else that goes in there's a
full cast and crew there that's big
money they don't do that just to give
people a alternative idea of what might
happen in the finale or something like
that this is probably real stuff that
they're filming so why would they do it
in front of a window well that means
that they're looking out that window
buts necessary that's why they're there
what would they be looking at is
something that we should be speculating
on and what exactly or where does this
fit in the timeline of the season dan
and Dave are both in these shots at
different times that leans a little bit
to what I was talking about yesterday of
maybe they're shooting the final episode
personally I think Cersei being alive is
not a good sign for that
I don't think Cersei will live till the
end David Nutter is also in these shots
so that means that yeah Dan and Dave are
there but they're writers and producers
they're the show runners obviously but I
mean they have other jobs there's other
hats that they wear beyond directors so
they could be there just completely for
that reason they're you know they're
they're talking about the writing or the
production and they want to be involved
this is their baby and it's the last
season so David Nutter being on the set
is the same sort of thing though why is
he there if they're not shooting one of
his episodes and we know that he's doing
episodes one two and four based on
everything else that we've seen coming
out of the filming I tend to think that
this is probably episode four we've seen
stuff going down at Winterfell we've
seen soldiers at the gate they could be
Lannister soldiers then we also saw
Winterfell the set at least burned down
and that leads me to believe that that
is probably something that happens
around the third episode because we know
they're gonna be shooting in the crypts
in the first couple episodes and things
like that in the interior of Winterfell
so that calamity whatever it is however
it ends up burning whether it be from
the night king or if Cersei played a
part in that herself
that's probably around the third episode
and that would be a good reason for Jon
to go down south and be like WTF you
just burnt down Winterfell or Winterfell
has burned down what are you gonna do
about it
because don't forget Cersei even though
we know she didn't plan on falling
through did pledged to help fight
against the dead alternative ideas could
be that yeah he doesn't wear his sword
he isn't where
his armor perhaps he is a captive in
that instance though why are they
looking out a window together not saying
it couldn't be the thing but the window
thing kind of makes me think that
they're looking at something and if
these two people are talking and it's in
the fourth episode I tend to think that
they're looking at something that Cersei
has grave concern about whether it be
dragons like I said I believe that John
will be riding a dragon by this time so
he probably came on dragon back
Daenerys might be there remember
yesterday we saw there was a character
that who might be her she may be there
for some filming so their dragons could
be outside the night King could be
approaching they could be looking at
burning as the countryside burns down
because we also know that they're
building up that big huge set outside of
Titanic with the intention of burning it
down as far as what we know
so Watchers on the wall says that
they're only filming there for a little
bit longer I did check the Dubrovnik
publications this morning to check if
they had any new shooting stuff and they
don't at least not at this point so it
looks like this is all we're gonna see
not that it's not a lot but I don't
think we're gonna get any more
conclusion as to what's actually
happening everything else they do in
King's Landing can be done at different
locations on the sound stages in the
studio things like that so outdoor shots
as far as them outside in King's Landing
are probably wrapped for the entire
season at this point at least the ones
they're doing in Croatia are as far as
we know a lot of theories have popped up
as to why these two people are meeting
in the last 24 hours since this came out
and the Croatian websites I'm interested
to hear what you guys think I don't
think we can draw any definite
conclusions from any of this but I think
that if I had to guess I would say that
John has come down after the fall of
Winterfell because he has no other
options the ones Winterfell Falls
there's nothing really stopping the dead
from marching south and by this time
he's seen plenty of
instances of what they can do we can
imagine the torment and barek and
everybody who was at the wall
not to mention that bran could see that
obviously everybody knows how they
walked through the wall everybody knows
that they're coming south and they're
bringing the winter with them and
they're gonna have to figure out
something if they want to stop them but
yeah let me know in the comments what
you guys think please like this video if
you enjoyed it subscribe to my channel
so you can follow along with all the
Game of Thrones filming news this season
with my videos and make sure you turn on
notifications by clicking on the little
bell so you'll know when a new video
comes out let's talk about it let's see
what we think no speculation is too wild
I just want to hear what you guys think
is going on you can also follow me on
social media and hit me up over there
that's it for now guys I'll talk to you
soon